Many operating systems allow you to submit bug reports
more or less automatically as soon as a program crashes.
This is the dialog that appears on a mac os system.
Essentially Apple asks you just one single question,
and that is again the steps necessary to reproduce the problem.
Everything else can be deduced from that one.
On top of that the bug report also includes
problem details and system configuration,
which is, for instance, the version number of the program that crashed,
the current process, date and time,
the functions that were active at the moment of the crash,
as well as any hardware attached to the machine.
Here are the steps needed to reproduce the problem,
and we send the whole thing to Apple.